Oh
what is up my flight we are on Twitch oh
my goodness gracious
what is up we're playing Marvel Ultimate
Alliance 3 the black order on switch and
we have a very very very special guest
joining us today the writer of Marvel
Ultimate Alliance through the black
order Mark suva reka what is up man hey
everybody I was so happy you could join
us
there's so much I want to ask you and
talk to you about it I'm sure chat is
gonna go crazy with questions because we
are so honor to have you here now just a
little bit about this game for those of
you who maybe are new to this or unsure
about what this game is to me this is
such a in depth RPG of some of your
favorite Marvel characters you can team
up some of your favorite villains heroes
all together up to four characters you
can do co-op you can do online there's
there's so much in it there's so much
customization in it in terms of outfits
and that's so that's that's what I would
say about the game mark I'm sure you
have some eloquent words yourself about
what this game means to you as well yeah
for me it's your chance to explore the
Marvel Universe using some of your
favorite characters there's over 50
characters on the final roster including
the DLC and so it's a really great
chance to take some of your favorites
team them up in unique combinations you
may never have before and let them
explore the Marvel Universe from end to
end in a chase for the Infinity stones
yeah that was what I said awesome so
right now we're doing a co-op campaign I
see you chose Latveria which is in the
third DLC that just came out called
shadow of doom so the game has its own
three DLCs that are out for in the
season pass you can go ahead and grab
them as well just make sure you have the
game before you get the DLCs and sure
we're doing this and we already facing
off against God in Purdue you're waiting
for me to ready up all right I see ya we
have a bunch of x-men on the bottom I
saw a Wolverine Cyclops who the other
two it was a storm and Colossus we're in
there that's gonna be good that's gonna
be a good synergy as well I'm excited
yeah it's always good to see psyche and
Colossus together some good reflective
capabilities there so we have a far
first question in chat this is a good
one what tips do you have for writing
for games you know it's really all about
being able to adapt a game you know no
matter what your vision for a story may
be no matter how singular of an idea you
may have games are made by a team so
when changes need to be made for
whatever reason whether it's gameplay or
level design you need to be able to make
those adjustments while still allowing
the heart of your vision in the story to
ring true it's not easy but when you can
make it happen it can be a lot of fun
you have my favorite storm outfit by the
way so you also have of course you also
write for comics what is the difference
and how does it how do you transition
from comic writing to videogame writing
you know really both share one important
aspect and that is knowing these
characters knowing what makes them tick
what makes them work at their core if
you have that understanding then it
doesn't really matter what medium you're
writing them in you know their voices
you know how they would react to things
now technically it's very different
because when you've got over 50
characters and a roster and you don't
know who's going to be playing with
which character at one point you have to
be able to adjust the situations as you
as right to fit all of those different
characters how they would react what
they would say so it's a much more broad
scale writing process you know you may
play the same four characters all the
way through the game but what you might
not realize is in all of those scenes
that those characters talk there are
other individual lines of dialogue for
the other forty some characters in the
roster that had to be written and
recorded so it's a very large scope
compared to comics but at the same time
and also a comic you know is 22 pages a
game is 10 hours so it's a whole lot of
how look a lot more in terms of overall
content that's that's perfect and you
are you're like you're so much into the
Marvel Universe as well like I feel like
you know so much about it now do you
have because of this game it's all about
the synergies right do you have two
characters that you just absolutely love
to writing their dialogue
together you know for me it was there
were two of two groups of characters
that I really enjoyed
I really enjoyed writing some of the
x-men characters together particularly I
liked writing Deadpool and Cape all
together because they have such a rich
history yeah and I also really enjoyed
writing rocket and Star work together
any scene that they're in was was just
absolute joy to write for me love love
the relationship between the two of them
and then as a third on that I really do
like write new younger characters so
Kamala Khan MS Marvel and Miles Morales
spider-man having those characters
together and spiders land in the mix you
know those scenes were such a blast
because they have such unique voices and
they speak to a totally different
audience than maybe the long-term
hardcore fan and it's me to introduce
those characters do new generation
that's good
so okay should we should we user e^x I
know we haven't send oh we should cut
down three oh you you're in it you're in
all right no it's good I've followed
your lead I think we got him Mattie X
should totally do it so when you're
playing this game in Kolbe whichever the
cool it's all about communication rights
like okay when do we use re X when do we
use our synergy bonuses stuff like that
just what difficulties hey I feel pretty
good Hey I think we were just on my T
that's awesome I thought we'd start you
know with the with the big guns and then
ease and whatever else like a cup of tea
I like that you know like start with an
appetizer first and yes yes now this man
this game has so many beautifully
crafted scenes did you have a favorite
scene that you worked on you know I
really loved that scene in level 2 the
raft
where the guardians have been going
through the raft with spider-man and
they get to the point where they've
defeated Sandman and all of the other
heroes start to teleport in via lockjaw
you could Captain America you get Iron
Man you get crystal you get Scarlet
Witch and Wolverine so there's like 10
characters who become playable at that
moment there's this nice little exchange
between wick fury
who arrives and rocket and star-lord
where they're all kind of meeting each
other in this adventure for the first
time and that was just so much fun to
get to bring all those characters
together I'll never forget when I first
play this game that exact scene you're
talking about
and then the camera zooms in to all of
the characters and they're all standing
there posing and I'm like mrs. amazed at
the end to that we expanded upon you
know you get that big group shot in that
level too and then here at the end of
the epilogue you see the entire roster
together yeah which you know if people
have finished the game they they have
seen but if they haven't it's a nice
little treat you get all 50 plus
characters that are playable in the game
except for good old fan oohs because
supposedly he's been defeated as doom
tries to take over the Alliance so we
have another question in chat what was
your number one favorite part of the
game that you wrote that you like to
write oh gosh you know my favorite part
in the writing process was whenever I
got to write one of those moments where
you walk up to a character for a
conversation you know so it's an NPC
character or characters it just appeared
in your roster and your playable
character gets to walk up to them and
have a brief conversation because I felt
like those moments got to add so much
extra character into the game and so
much background and depth as to
individual points of view that you might
never get if you're not playing as those
characters so you get to meet everybody
throughout the course of the game which
is really nice you can skip them if you
want to I'll be sad but you could
totally skip by him and still enjoy the
game but they add an extra depth if you
want it so I'm that type of gamer where
I'll talk to every single character I
possibly can because I want to know the
lore about it I want to I want to hear
what they have to say and I I did all of
it I remember I was playing with her
friends with the first game Kate first
came out and they're just like at first
there's like what are you doing why
talking everybody but like three minutes
in they're just like wait talk to
everybody
awesome so let's let's get into this
again
see how where's-where's I think your
host in the room so if you want to get
us to somewhere cool oh yeah let's see
let's see here rube details okay here we
go okay so let's keep with story let's
let's make it suit let's go superior I
think we do superior yeah now let's
choose missions here okay so this is the
DLC three shadow of doom do you want how
do you feel do you want to stick with
okay let's take a tour of the Marvel
Universe wait what's your favorite
locale in the game I like I like a lot
of them but I know that for me the ads
garden level was great
because we got to have not only the
scene in hell but also the scene in the
Asgardian palace as it was overtaken by
Hydra I'm such a lot of variety in that
level that was a lot of fun great let's
let's go back and then cuz I'm on the DL
C 3 okay here we go
so now we're in the main one so now we
could choose all of those missions in
there I'll create a room for us so let's
do that one my favorite would personally
be nowhere where you're facing off
against everyone in the black order and
you're going through and then you face
up against Thanos and then you face
nothing it's faith it's like it's just
this epic oh man but let's do you say
you mentioned Asgard yes do we wanna
stop for the beginning yes let's start
let's start road to hell it's our in the
beginning like that cool okay two
players I'm gonna make the password one
two and three just because that's easy
to remember
also chat let us know if some characters
you want us to play as ears like I love
this character I want to see let us know
cuz we're choosing characters and we
want to show we want to showcase your
favorite Marvel characters absolutely
it's a deep roster you know that's one
of the great things about this game is
not only are there your fan favorites
but we get to also have a lot of
characters that people don't normally
know you know from the first to Marvel
Ultimate Alliance games a lot of people
met Moon Knight and Deadpool for the
very first time people who weren't comic
readers and so in this game we wanted to
make sure there were some of those
characters as well characters like Elsa
bloodstone who may be non comic readers
don't know but comic readers love
because she's super fun and she's a you
know kick butt British Monster Hunter so
you go with Deadpool yeah we got another
okay so we got we got Moon Knight
alright so Moon Knight I'm gonna choose
cable just because we got to have a
Deadpool on cable to go especially after
you mentioned you love writing for them
we got and it will do daredevil alright
daredevil is one of my high-level
characters at 1:47 you can now level up
your characters to 300 so please don't
like that that's good we also have
another question when you wrote for this
game did you have to write only for the
characters or did you write parts of the
story and the levels etc well you know
the process really started with the
story as a whole you know it started as
as where we wanted to go in terms of our
direction through the Marvel Universe
and who the villains were going to be
and from there we kind of staged out
scenes and made sure that everything fit
together the characters within each
scene kind of happened organically you
know as as we realized who fit within
each environment and where they should
be introduced then you'll start to see
how everybody everybody starts to click
together in the cutscenes and where
everything falls into place so really it
started with story and then built
through with character from there you
know and and there were you know it was
just as much time figuring out who the
villains were gonna be as as it was
figuring out who the heroes were gonna
be because we wanted to make sure not
only do we have some fan favorites we
had some deep cuts we wanted to make
sure that everybody kind of melded
together naturally
where they appear we didn't want to just
randomly have you know MODOK appear
somewhere he wouldn't naturally fit so
obviously aim is a science-based
group and they'd be invading Wakanda to
try to get some vibranium and that was a
very natural fit there so it was all
about just making sense of where all
these pieces fit together well you wrote
for these characters did you ever like
hear what they had like if you could
imagine what their voice would sound
like did you ever say it out loud in
their voice Oh Josh it's true I mean I
think I've been writing for Marvel for
and so when I wake up in the morning who
was in my brain and it's not a good fake
all the time you know especially like
when I'm hanging out with my
six-year-old but mostly you know these
characters speak to me in a way that if
I'm given a situation with with whether
it's spider-man or Deadpool or Captain
America I know how they're gonna react I
know what they're going to say compared
to a different character in the same
situation so it's you're using my best
judgment in that area and think that I
can pull off the voice that everybody's
looking for
and I can then it's a win and if I can't
then I've luckily got the amazing team
at Marvel games to back me up and point
me in the right direction
oh no you definitely did you definitely
did now I'm so curious to hear what your
Deadpool impression
like just the ability to you know to
take this game on the go to I think is
really cool yeah
because for being an exclusive on the
switch you're just like take it with you
put in your bag and pop it out like if
you're in a park you're at a friend's
house you just go hey let's let's level
up some characters let's do it right
yeah he's really nice the portability
and the compatibility of multiplayer was
a huge deal for you know this franchise
because that's what the original
Ultimate Alliance games were all about
it was all about making sure that you
were having fun playing co-op that was a
huge huge part of it yes the story was
fun the characters were awesome but
co-op was what really made it special
and when the switch became you know a
system and when the bar became his team
it was gonna be made for the coffered ok
these questions these questions are
coming in hot oh this is great what hair
product do you use mark I'm freshly go
off Flo's saying this is very long hair
too I want to catch up on the Marvel
timeline in comics where do I start
what's a good starting point for Marvel
calm oh man that's a really good
question you know in terms of the modern
comic era it depends on the family of
titles that you're looking to catch up
on you know it whether it's if you
really love Avengers stuff or x-men
stuff there have been some really good
starting points in in recent years you
know if you're an x-men fan absolutely
house that is Jonathan Hickman and just
unbelievable you know magnum opus of
x-men stories it's great stuff so that's
worth checking out you know when it
comes to the Avengers there there have
been plenty of great runs in recent
history to check out and and the current
stuff that Jason Aaron is doing is just
wonderful Jason Aaron and McGinnis
relaunched it
and we'll do it and man those are big
breaks you know that hair you know if
you're looking for Earth or you know
there's there's some great stuff that
Donnie Cates is doing right now and also
a Ewing run on guardians of the galaxy
it's a really strong start so I mean
there's there's you can pick up
virtually any Marva title and even on
the ground floor but there are plenty of
great new recent mark what character do
you relate to most and why in this
roster you know I'd probably say well
Pete is just the everyman character he's
that character that we all as writers
and as readers put a little bit of
ourselves into
you know he's designed specifically that
way he could not be a more brilliant
design from in that is all of us he has
our problems he has our our worries and
sometimes they supersede what he does as
a hero or they inform what he does as a
hero I think and I think that's really
important about I think that's really
special about him and I think in the
modern day version of spider-man and
Miles Morales I think you see just as
much of that but from a slightly
different perspective and I think it's
painful so either of the Spider Men are
characters that I I really feel my heart
in when I'm writing if I think of a
Marvel character it has the most heart I
my first gut reaction for piyah be
spider-man yeah for sure yeah there are
so many to choose from though and so
many of them have different important
motivations so it really depends on how
you define heart and you to do the most
you know I I have friends who wouldn't
want to read spider-man book to save
their lives but they get the x-men they
understand the x-men and where they're
coming from and how they live and
breathe and that's that's their bread
butter and so it really just depends on
who you are and what you feel
foster characters is diverse enough that
you know you can you can really pick and
choose and find a favorite of your own
and that makes it special
I totally are getting roster is the same
way yes I keep accidentally hitting e^x
hey it's happening it's working he like
yeah I see that
you knew I'm so it's good you do the
rest of it we get some moon night action
in here he's so much fun to play he's so
much fun he was one of my go-to czar the
first dates I used to love playing his
moon night back in the originals so get
him into the dlc was was a real awesome
thing his moveset is a lot of fun to
play he's got some real power the way he
glides to is just oh there you go there
we go again okay you'll be able to see
it uh who are the voice actors that
especially made your writing sound
exactly like you expected or even better
that's a great question uh you know
nolan north who did both deadpool and
rockets is is the voice-over pro of the
world you know he's the guy he's the MVP
so he just did such an amazing job
bringing those new characters life and
those two characters bring a lot of
humor again just by their nature so
having him be able to keep both of those
and to understand all of them so well at
their center to make them sound
different enough even though they have
the same snarky attitude that when they
deliver their lines we don't mistake
them for each other was was really
impressive it was a a master class
watching him record you know there was
so many great people ski
to watch James Arnold Taylor I did the
wrist goes on and on
amazing talent that we were fortunate
enough to have work on this game oh my
gosh I'm are you did the voice work for
blade was unbelievable that was one that
really surprised me because I had
written these blade lines it was my
first time writing blade I think and I
wrote these lines when he walked into
that booth it was just like you know he
had stepped out of the movie and it
really was some specialist that's
awesome
favorite NPC in the game in parentheses
you know I love absolutely and on top of
that I also really enjoyed Winter
Soldier in the game I thought that
having him play a role in the game I
would have loved you know to see them
both and expanded roles but the having
them both as NPC's in the game was
phenomenal really really enjoyed that of
course big theory who doesn't want to
write for Nick Fury where are you going
why you exiting the level I'm trying to
I try to show the ruler your beautiful
writing so I'm talking to the IMP I was
there oh is there any big challenge on
writing for a game different than a
comic you know it's just really it
really is and keeping track of things
you know the interesting thing about it
reading game is you can make a small
change in level three that impacts a
huge scene in level seven and when you
make that small change
you don't always realize it right off
the bat that oh my gosh this is gonna
have that butterfly effect and impact
everything down the road it might just
be hey we you know you couldn't fit this
certain thing in the level or if we
needed to change the design and so we're
gonna cut the scene or we're gonna
expand it in a different direction and
then when you get down later and you go
home and then you know that scene we
reference there is there
has changed then you've got to have that
ripple effect where you know it's all
about continuity and keeping track so
that makes sense and when you're in a
game and you've got hundreds of pages of
dialogue and thousands of lines that
you've written it can be a challenge to
make sure that it's all lining up so you
mentioned earlier that you might you
felt like sometimes he was showcasing
some Marvel characters for the first
time to fans yeah how did you find the
balance to spotlight those with such a
large roster you know it really was
about working together as a team with
Marvel games and Team Ninja and Nintendo
to make sure that we had enough
characters of the long term fans enough
characters that really just made sense
to keep in the roster because people
wanted them and loved them with people
with voices or power sets that might be
different and unique you know we wanted
to make sure that not only were all
these characters fun to listen to and
important to the story but also that
they were fun to play and that we didn't
have too many characters who overlapped
in terms of powers or too many
characters who overlapped in terms of
personality so we made huge lists huge
lists you know lists that were probably
three times the size of what's roster
ended up being of characters we brought
to include and then we went through them
together and whittled it down and you
got this core group of these and yes
this is this is the balanced roster that
we're looking for this is you know these
are the characters that bring out the
very best o of what not only the Marvel
Universe has to offer but what this
particular game
how did the writing process start from
Lua 3 yeah how did it all start
you know it all started Danny Danny ku
who's a senior producer who had been
working with me on I had been working
him rather on another project mobile
game cuz I do some writing for Horsham
multiple games were from Marchesa and he
called me one night and said hey man
I've got a project that needs a story
outline put together don't know if you
have any interest in it but you know hit
me up and so I call the Mackeson well
sure Danny you know I'm always
interested in a new project and you know
give me some details on what it is and
there was kind of a pause and he he said
oh it might be you know and you know I
played the original - back in my my xbox
days and and said you know this this
would be amazing so I was all in you
know once once I knew what it was I was
gonna be all in anyway because I liked
writing stuff and I liked writing games
but that was really you know a
no-brainer for me it was a perfect fit
because I had such a connection each of
those earlier games personally as a
player at what point were you able to
tell your friends and family that you
got to work on this game you know my
wife knew for you know early on because
she was there with me while I was
deciding you know how to how to take the
journey and while I was locked away in
my office writing for many months
actually many years but but when it
comes to you know the broader scope of
it you know I kind of I kept the secret
for a good long time you know I didn't
let people people who I was working on a
project but family and friends didn't
know until right about when we were up
to announce it you know when we when we
were gosh when you it was in that a
Nintendo Direct the December before it
released was when we first announced it
was I'm sorry wasn't interval was on the
video game once was where they announced
it and so yeah it was you know I kept
that secret really really close to that
deadline wasn't easy though when you're
working on something like this you want
to tell everybody you want
throughout the world to know for sure
especially you being such a big fan of
these games right right know the
originals who for like two years had no
idea that I had any connection to a new
one or that a new one hang out and they
talked about the old game and I just
have to keep it all inside bottled up so
it was nice to finally get to talk about
it when we did
was there any character you dreamed of
writing that you were able to write it
for the very first time oh we're doing
it alright we're doing it I was gonna
wait to be stunned but that's okay the
the you know one of the characters that
I really enjoyed writing that I've
written for the first time was Loki I
don't think I never had the chance to
write Loki before that really cool get
into his voice and into his head you
know I loved and so getting to bring him
to life and hear his voice was fun a lot
a lot of good material in this level
especially you know there's some good
clothes again cool to get to see him
throughout the game in kind of as the
trickster that he is he kind of pops up
throughout the game now at that so it
was nice to play with him
we're gonna come in a chat Loki loved
Loki yeah via these transitions this
transitions for this level specifically
was just so epic how you go from Hell to
the Rainbow Bridge yeah it's just right
there and then how you go into Asgard
and you face off against the Red Skull
and the destroyer comes in well that
build is very deliberate you know when
we were putting together the game and
figuring out what the destinations were
going to you know we wanted it to be a
tour of the modern changed a lot since
the last
the lion takes you know it's been 10
years since previous offic Alliance came
and so we got to see a lot of the
locations in the Marvel Universe room
back then but new families of characters
have come to prominence you know we like
the guardians of the galaxy and some of
those younger characters I mentioned
earlier files that worked in those games
so it was all about making sure you know
so we got that first the first level
where they're on the starship and then
all the sudden it's dark dimension and
it's dududud yes as garden sections of
Asgard to nowhere where you fight the
whole black order so we wanted it to get
bigger and bigger and bigger we wanted
to make sure that that tool bar in the
Marvel Universe was escalating and it
definitely did feel that way every level
just felt bigger than the previous one
and just kept on escalating as you
mentioned the biggest surprise that they
get this game for me was when you think
you defeated Fame but that he comes back
earthers that we you know for those who
don't who haven't played the game or
don't know the comics theme as the Sun
of manners and you know when we were
figuring out who we wanted to use as her
heart major fiddling you know the answer
the obvious answer was thinners
the obvious answer was Santos because
he's chasing the infinity gems and the
black border are his you know his
minions and shirts too but we've seen
that before right we've seen battles
will chase the infinity gems for dozen
times and we've seen that final battle a
dozen times in different ways over
different media but then we thought
ma'am wouldn't it be cool if we did a
slightly different twist on it wouldn't
it be cool if since we're using Fane in
this story what if we brought him in you
know to follow in his father's footsteps
in a way that at first he thinks is
noble but then deteriorates due to you
know this this strange quest for power
that his family can't seem to escape so
so bringing that into the mix I'm having
fan oohs kind of have to almost switch
sides at the end even though it's for
his own his own devious needs was a fun
way to stage the final boss battles that
maybe we wouldn't have done
yeah they I was I was cuz I love I love
pain as a character I was very surprised
back oh man okay that was back from the
infinity crossover from and then he was
he was in a recent Fano series for a
while as well and just through the
gundam greatly as a character we enjoyed
him thought so we thought it was a
natural fit to bring him into them from
the teenager folk and also from from
jin-sang I mean like you said it takes a
team and the fact that you know
especially with this game Marvel games
the team are fans that love this so much
that live in this universe and and they
put so much care and love into it should
we change your characters how we feeling
yeah sure
let's give some love to some more more
this beautiful roster guys let us know
in chat I should give you guys some more
heads up let me know Chen who you guys
want to see I know I saw some miles in
there earlier let's see we could do an
entire spidey spider synergy which one
do you want I'll let you have because
you know what's great about miles while
you're selecting your characters one of
the things I love about Myles is he had
the potential you know all of the spider
characters have a potential to just be
another spider-man in your roster in
terms of gameplay style but the team at
Team Ninja when they were balanced now
the gameplay made really sure to make
sure they all had their own special
attributes that they were all you know
they all have their own unique power so
Myles uses a lot of his bio electricity
he uses it's camouflage D in the comics
and that you know is a real nice
addition to the standard spider powers
that the Peter Parker spider-man hands
and when is the same wake when uses her
her teleportation abilities because
she's from a different mentioned to kind
of add an extra mix into her fighting
style turns it's like a venom whale and
comes up from the ground and just yeah
we're protoplasm sharp oh let me know
when uh when you got miles and we got
more questions in chat chat is going
wild I love this I'm ready to go oh yes
let's do it
start did you did you start up yeah well
I'm figuring this out these characters
have gone through a ton of iterations
from comics and shows and movies how do
you decide which voices and attitudes to
write in and were there any of were
there any you actively put a new spin to
with this game you know for the a game
like this it's all about distilling it
down I love this oh you have enough oh
yes I love that miles actually the punk
rock storm and diss miles are my two
favorite so so when it comes to it's a
really good question when it comes to
writing which version of the character
it's all about distilling it down into
the core of the character you got to
remember that whether you're playing the
game or watching the movie or reading a
comic every time you eat these
characters could be somebody's first and
you don't know where people are coming
in from you don't know if they're just
movie fans or if they're fans in the
cartoons or if they're fans the comments
so you've got to have a you know a
well-rounded view of who this character
is so is it it isn't jarring to them so
that they they recognize their favorite
character so for me it's all about
taking the core of the character and
making sure that they bring truth and
then taking elements from my favorite
bits and pieces so there's definitely a
lot
movie star Gordon and rocket in their
voices and interactions just because
their voices and interactions and the
ups are so much fun but it's not
necessarily the proportion you character
it's just inspiration distilled from all
of those sources just being able to to
talk to you while playing this game is
like can check that off my dream list
cool but you know you know deep down you
love telling stories we love Queen's
characters that we grew up with and we
want to do the best camera want to tell
the best stories we can run the best
games we can and it really you know is
all about passion it's all about
characters and their legacy so it's it's
a lot of the shoulders of somebody's
loves these things to make sure that
they're not doing them you know there's
there's always that worry of you know am
I am i doing stand proud if I get the
jacket proud you know with with this
version of the character be something
that everybody loves but at the same
time we're working with such a strong
love this game but I can't beat Ultron
in any suggestions
Ultron it's all that matter his laser
sprites time where his where his drones
appear
you know those Ultron sentries that show
up they come with specific times and
they shoot their lasers and specific
pattern so for me the way that I beat
Ultron is all about justice you maybe
get hit once or twice as I watch the
pattern and then going from there I
would for me I'd recommend if you have a
character that you've unlocked that can
fly who's very very helpful for mobility
in terms of getting out
beam's and second the second thing when
you're on that on that like turret if
you will and you're shooting Ultron what
you want to do is while the Ultron BOTS
are aiming at you at the last second
dodge left so the beams go left and then
walk there and then dodge back to the
turret so the beam doesn't follow you so
you can keep on still taking on Ultron
and I mean the Ultron it depends on but
then there's also the ultimate yes upon
rooftop so and those are very different
animals because that ultimate battle has
the turrets and still a lot of Ultron
sentries to fight but it's it's got a
you know there's there's a whole lot of
extra going on there oh yeah I was
talking you're right I was talk about
the ultimate foot you're right you're
right all right Ultron is on okay yeah
he didn't that's right that's right
that's right
well flyers were really good for that
battle for Ultron because he does those
midair laser stripes you know he's got
the the moving laser beam sprites that
kind of cascade across the field of play
having to fly her there to dodge them
and Mark are you much of a game of
yourself as you are right over there yes
I am it's changed over the years you
know now that I have kids I play a lot
more casual games than I just do you
know I used to be a lot harder cooler in
terms of gaming and and now you know I
use my hours when when my kids want to
play we're gonna play all kinds of stuff
on the switch that is more
family-friendly but it still it still
bills
so but then when they oversleep question
chat mark did you enjoy writing for
Morbius and doom I did how could you not
oh god I hope it's shown that I enjoyed
writing for you because he is just so
over the top and ridiculous as a bill
and I have a deep respect for do my I
was furrow a long period of time I was
the assistant editor and asked for under
Tom Brevoort and and just my
appreciation for doom especially with
Wade was writing and during her period
was was deep you know doom was just one
of those characters who has so much
gravitas and can be really silly and
goofy and over-the-top if you want him
to me but can also be exceptionally
threatening when we when used well and
so you know yes he's got that
third-person voice and and you know
ridiculous ego but at the same time he's
also you know a really deep rooted
character Morbius to I think this may
have been the first time I wrote
previous so I had you know III was a fan
of the care of her from all sorts of
different venues from the comics
infirmary and made series of sorts of
stuff but you know this was the first
time that I'd actually got him that was
that was fun too you know he's one of
those characters had a lot of disparate
versions of him over the years you know
whether it's been the scientist who's
fighting his own hunger science or
whether he's kind of more gothy McCobb
vampire type
so let's cut that brings me to an
interesting question so first some
characters that you maybe wrote for the
first time did you like learn something
like what was something that you learned
new that you just that's caught you a
surprise or Cuddy's like oh man I see
this character like a different light
you know it's it's not necessarily a
specific instance that I can think of
off the top of my head but it really was
the the joy of getting to kind of put
those those voices into the rolodex in
my brain you know because when written
character throw tide you just get you
can familiar with it and so when you
have to introduce yourself to a new
voice to a new character you really
stretch the muscles that you haven't
necessarily used writing the other
things and so for me writing character
like Elsa bloodstone
he's just so cheeky and so you know fun
and and Sue's confidence yeah she's so
unlike so many of the other characters
out there and so writing was you know
just such a fun experiment there was no
one else at that I mean that I was
writing who was like her you know and
the same goes for you know a character
like The Punisher I found myself just
laughing my head off punished because
there's for some of these characters I
was giving you you know expository
answers as to what's happened in the day
but the phrase like a shot
no it's helpful so it was it was fun to
kind of see how these different
characters how those applied to the same
question for mark and Josh if you could
live the life of any Marvel superhero
who would it be
that's a question I mean every man I'll
let you go first if you have one from
from this roster I would mind star you
know explore the universe but also
having that that love of his homeworld
and and getting to you know bridge that
gap between the cosmos and her birth and
see all kinds of things that that weird
love pop culture that he has tied
together I think I think I make an okay
start maybe not legendary but I'd be
okay a star-lord who's got better dreams
you were star-lord but yeah I mean that
would be that would be a great one but
of course who doesn't who's got who's
got better dance moves you were you were
star-lord I feel like I feel like oh man
that's such a tough question my first
reaction probably Captain America just
because of what he stands for and the
power that he has and just the morality
that he has and you know if another
Marvel character speaks to more talk to
him they immediately like look up to him
in a sense that you stand for something
so powerful and strong but then there's
also the other side of that like if I
want to be a rich millionaire Tony Stark
sounds really cool to be how long did it
take you to write the full game script
well gosh you know it's it's hard to
remember at this point but we worked on
the game for about two years you know
before we started the dlc and then for
year after that or so yeah just rough
estimates so it was a long process I
mean there's
develop those into video games you know
because once you start then you're
seeing on the screen every individual
somebody has to design so it was and
seeing the designs rule you know that
was one of my favorite things sure you
know I'm writing so you know I don't
necessarily have a ton of saying in you
know what cost me and somebody's wearing
or what you know what do your villains
are gonna be designed like normally what
the Marvel game is so collaborative an
inside CEO would it be what about this
could we draw inspiration from here from
level and it just made it so I believe
who's gonna be a shield point here so
I'm gonna say yeah there he goes
let us know what care does its do
another character swap let us know what
character you want us to play as I can
look at that miles and that Gwen I'm all
day
another question well while we're going
through this while we're waiting for you
guys to give us characters which
characters in the game did you write for
the first time well I for sure I wrote
Loki for the first time Elsa bloodstone
I wrote for the first time I'm pretty
sure midnight obvious it was my first
try on them you know I add see who else
couple of the x-men characters I don't
think I had ever had the chance to write
classes before and that was great I
loved writing him he's just he's such a
cool character that that you know
dichotomy within him of being such a
strong strong character but also being
such a a peaceful man was really fun to
play with so yeah there are a bunch you
know a lot of my history in heart versus
in the Avenger
family of titles and so it was to get to
expand beyond that to some of the others
so we have a lot of we have a thing we
have a villian team we have mr.
fantastic villain team I'm also gonna
hide our videos for this they can still
hear us just so they can see the entire
roster yes and it's all of its beauty
so villain team I mean if we're gonna go
with villain team I gotta choose
infinite Thanos who you going for and we
could question that you know but but
kind of all of them are questionable in
that area that's for to pursue I mean
frankly I see Punisher as a villain
that's just me
you know there's Loki you know he could
be hero villain depending on the day and
and how he wakes up there's Deadpool
there they're both on the edge of being
either depending on it who they need to
be that day Loki yeah Loki Loki do
magneto and San Jose okay that's that's
good that's good
we could even go by villains category in
the game as well which is the characters
that you mentioned oh man do doom so
good a which piece of advice would you
give to a creator who wants to write for
games you know for me it's a it if you
want to write games in the Marvel
Universe it's fun content about knowing
who these characters are and and what
the is how it all fits together
whether if you're working on you know
existing characters in any license
that's that's the case you have to know
these worlds like the back of your hand
when it comes to writing games in
general you know it's it's all about
knowing the scale and scope of it all
and realizing how big a project is and
how collaborative is and how you need to
adapt a long way to make sure that not
only do things fit the story you want to
tell but the story you want to tell fits
the style of game
that it's going into so it's about
balance about finding that that
collaborative adaptability with your
team to bring it all to life
ready ah did you have you ready that by
the way I'm asking you come on you can
you can answer questions play the same
time right it's so hard it's such a hard
muscle to do what was it like writing
for Elsa bloodstone loved her I mean you
know hey I got to learn a lot of fun
cheeky British slang but on top of that
she's just such a different voice so so
you know whether you know blood Elsa
from next wave or from her own title or
from the recent run attendance by Kelly
Thompson you know what wherever you know
the from personality always shines just
in amazing way she's this terrible
there's so much
you
the potential donors I mean there are
just as many villains and persons there
are heroes and so you know obviously we
all had our wishlist it's coming in see
in this game who had been in previous
games that we'd love to see again and
who has never been in a Altima twice
game before wanted to make sure to
feature but it was you know was a
clamorous been just like the playable
roster we wanted to go in and make sure
that we had a good balance and that
everybody was a natural fit the theme
and the narrative you didn't want to
Punk anybody's randomly in 211 for any
big for example you know because he was
you know scientific group and Lokhande
is a scientific nation you know one of
the one of the ones that was really kind
of a curve ball for us was Red Skull
who's coming up here because we wanted
to do something totally different with
him that hasn't been necessarily seen in
other games and we didn't know you know
exactly and first we're you know what
would be the best fit for him should we
should we face 11 now you know
Washington DC or should we face a level
should keep Avengers oh and then we
kicked around the idea of what Hydra you
know well all the other heroes were
saving the universe wouldn't it make
sense of the Red Skull in his movie and
did something and so while the heroes
are off chasing Infinity stones but it's
going in gathering ISO eight and it gets
enough power to power up high take over
you know so that's the kind of stuff
that you're looking for could you use
these characters and we can different
ways that we're still true to who they
would
that was other those geniusly what is
fritz go do it with bleakman teamed up
with hello what what is happening yeah
and there's that moment you know before
you realize what's happening where you
fight you're waiting reality
white howlite and she mentions that
she's teamed up yet and you run across
the Rainbow Bridge app server and
there's a blockade of height for
soldiers we wanted that to be a really
unexpected moment you know why is Hydra
in an ass garden what are they doing and
whooping them what is their plan and how
does it tie into everything else because
it was just me we wanted it to be one of
those weird laughter B's that nobody
expected market dialogue there there are
something not that I definitely really
enjoyed hearing the things that I write
but there are still some that I go back
and I chuckle and you know there's
whenever went nebula says you idiots who
doomed the universe and rocket those
wouldn't be the first time sweetheart
that to me is a really when Nick Fury
says to rocket and Iron Man measure your
weapons later I you know that just in
Nick Fury's voice it just works great
and then there's the DLC there's this
moment where over the wall so we gotta
we gotta get him from behind the wall in
the DLC pack they said it wouldn't
happen but but it came true we got some
sweet dlc action and cable goes i have
no idea what you're talking about
and he goes yeah you'll see Deadpool
looks capable and and it's one of those
things where you know it's a little nod
to the game Deadpool is legendary for
breaking but it
so talking about the DLCs you know
there's so many different characters
story elements how early did you work on
those and you know how excited were you
to get to play with even more characters
in this world you know it was it was so
cool when I found out that we were doing
we had been hard at work on the main
story and building that for you know a
year and a half or so and and we really
didn't obviously get working on the DLC
stuff until the story elements were
wrapped up in the main stories and you
know they were putting the final touches
on humming cramming it on the design of
it all once I was done with my story
aspects that's when I shifted my focus
over the DLC so is you know much much
later in the game the journal title but
by then we had such a good understanding
of what this world was and and what the
type of story was we were telling that
we knew characters who would be a
natural fit we knew characters who
sorely missed by you know fans as the
roster was announced but we also knew
characters that you know would expand
the experience of the game so that's
when you know we started really
narrowing down the ideas of batches the
characters would be you know obviously
the FF was a little bit easy to lock
down then then some of the other packs
of four in the victim of DLC because but
the day I found out that dude was doing
a playable character was because I how
could you not walk play is huge in this
game and so when we kind of surprised
the world oh because everybody just
assumed it was going to be three four
player you know three four character
packs because the first two were when we
had that fifth slot for four do that and
then after you finish the DLC pack
then you're like wait why is there why
is there another spot what is this
right Bannos infinite yeah I was a you
know one of those things where early on
that we wanted to make sure that if you
were in the game that he wasn't
necessarily overpowered and that he was
on par with the other characters because
if he had the Infinity drop I keep just
keep just with everything but but then
at the end you know once you beat the
ultimate difficult to get all the levels
why not you know why not have that super
bonus character that is the ultimate
unlock and has the stone powers tied
right into it gameplay because that's
you know that's something that kind of
really puts a nice end Kathleen the game
and a body designed for total
annihilation yes is there anything you
thought wouldn't make it into the game
that did not necessarily you know it's
it's so hard to say because when you're
writing a script for a video game it
goes through a lot of iterations goes
through all different versions and you
know you make a lot of changes as you go
but you you adapt and you ship your
perspective on what the levels are gonna
be you know depending on what those
gameplay changes are those design
changes are hard and so it's really hard
you know by the end of the day to say
was there something specific that made
it in or didn't thank you Tim that I
would have loved because I think it
ended up being what it was supposed to
be to have a cop-out answer but I am
really happy with the final story and
ended up as that I don't really miss
anything and I don't necessarily feel
like anything didn't work or snuck in
because I you know I didn't think was
going to but you know it all belonged
there so that's that's at least my hope
I hope that it comes off that way
certainly designed it for me
it absolutely absent ours in this game
[Music]
so how many drafts of the script you
write a little kind of the way I wrote
this particular was level by level you
know I wrote I wrote them all together
entire script the story in the narrative
but then what you're doing with new
drafts it's usually based on changes
within individuals or within individual
sections so you go back and revise in
chunks and go back so it wasn't
necessarily you know I'd say you know
ten full drafts of the script but maybe
one level had sixteen drafts whereas
another one had because not a lot of
changes needed made in terms of gameplay
or in terms of in errors so it all
balances out I'd say well you know we
probably did you know ten to twelve full
passes through the games and get it home
down to one it has to be that's my rough
estimate I wouldn't be surprised if you
know that were a very very common thing
other games like that a lot of
innovations in different different
sections
so I want to do one more before so I'm
gonna get into I want to get into the
danger room with us so we eats a weave
okay saw 1v1 but before we do that I'm
gonna do one more mission you can do
small one but I want to do an all female
character females for our favorite
because we keep on mentioning Elsa
bloodstone so we got a show-off Elsa
bloodstone for sure mark who is your
favorite villain in this game you know
my favorite villain right
might have been MODOK just because he's
so off the wall so I also really enjoyed
writing hell she really pulls it off and
so that was that was fun in terms of
gameplay boss to fight against I would
say that I really really liked the
battle with Red Skull and destroyer that
we just did
that one's a lot of fun I also really
liked the battles in the x-mansion that
whole level just progresses so Malcolm
and there are so many fill-in set pieces
within that x-men level whether you're
fighting juggernaut do you need o or the
Infinity Sentinel glade approximate big
night it just builds and builds
throughout that level it's coming in
chat I just wanted to say thank you for
your work on the game I've been a moola
fan since the first one and really
enjoyed the ability to play moolah 3
anywhere us too
you know and that's right there with you
so many of us that made this game of
this series from the get-go and so we
wanted to do a crowd in question thank
you which character in your opinion has
best arc
oh that's a big question
Wow well and the thing is they've had so
many so many of these characters have
been around you know 60 to 80 years
really hard to narrow it down you know
in terms of growth there are characters
like Kitty Pryde we have really just
we've watched them especially kitty now
teenager - the best captain of the
moderns you know and I mean what
transformation she's you know but then
there are long-term characters that you
look at like you like the hostesses who
you don't just look at his arc look at
the quirks of the character around James
you see what being folk means through a
variety of different characters and I
think that's special to you know that
legacy is real so you know it's it's
hard to pimp just wasn't along but yeah
you know recently come back and read
more comics oh now you're like now we're
like you want to break the boxes come on
there's something up there
yeah it's nowhere it's a giant skull in
space space called space skull
these are so good good yeah team ninja
did some amazing on these cutscenes and
just really really brought this world
there's I love he speaks to you in brain
telepathic Russian oh man that's another
thing that I absolutely would like laugh
so loud the the flavor text underneath
character name there's one I can't
remember it was like during the the
after right after the Sandman battle you
there's one that just like maybe get I
guess like what you know the the goal
those those little flavor text those
little subtitles was basically to give
you an idea of who the character was in
a quick nutshell you know it was it was
how can some of this character in you
know 50 letters or less just to let
people they're playing at and man they
were they were a fun little challenge to
not only get across who they were in
terms of personality but also to add a
little humor to them as well and those
went over pretty well people liked him I
don't know how you managed to do that
being able to describe these Marvel
characters in like a sentence or less
props man well thanks thanks it's you
know it again it's it's really just
having a deep love these characters and
knowing for me you know gosh I've know
yeah I've been a Marvel reader since I
was four or five years old which was far
longer ago than I'd like to admit and
you have been working from full since 99
so it's you know it's it's in the blood
getting to know these characters is is
has been a real joy and getting to be a
part of that legacy is or so so we I'm
get I was I'm a guessing you'd want to
go with Elsa but let me know if you want
to go with somebody else cuz I could
choose sweet yeah I got storm Invisible
Woman and feed
[Music]
Oh May they're just like cozy look at
that they're ready they're ready loving
yeah this storm the storm outfit is one
of my favorites yeah there's some really
cool costumes there's there some really
really Planet Hulk costumes beautiful
bed slopes not only this declan's taco
costume but there's that battle of the
atom version of Deadpool you got that
great old man Logan yeah captain
Marvel's old Miss Marvel her birth
costume and then also you know Kamala
and Myles both have it and they're kind
of hip street wear looks nice man that
age of apocalypse costumes on colossi I
really love Team Rayce yeah I think I
also like that you can be Phoenix
oh there's so many epic moments in the
thing I think my favorite thing about
this game I'm gonna break out why I put
a hundred plus hours of this game is
that there's always something new to
unlock it to you you can you know it's
for the perfect casual game or it could
be for the hardcore someone who just
wants to play the storyline awesome but
if you call those costumes if you want
to level up if you want to get all those
yeah when I play with my kid on my own
to wear one of my favorite questions we
got into chat as well what's it like
working for Marvin that's a dream come
true you know it's everybody loves
comics everybody have Irish writer it's
a great week um everybody who loves
comics everybody who loves these
characters knew he's careful furs you
know has a special place for them in
their hairs so when when I got the
opportunity to walk through those doors
and to be a part the team you know the
best opportunities of my life
I certainly that's not to wait so I made
so many dear friends in this community
in a year and across the with so many
talented people in so many different
capacities that I really couldn't feel
more fortunate it's a real to just be a
part of this legacy a small part
in comparison to some creative whose
shoulders I stand wised but you know to
get to be a part of it glasses something
special so I think we don't have a lot
of time left I'll leave it up to you if
you want to continue this mode the
storyline or do you want to do dangerous
I'm happy you know I'm cool just you
know grind and brew some want some black
boys first we got we got have any ma
here we're coming up in the collectors
museum so we can do some battle plus I
don't want you to I don't you can
embarrass work you know what we're all
but for those of you who are you know
don't unsure what the danger room is
it's this amazing PvP basically you're
in your own level they're in their own
level and go and there's different
challenges in terms of time there's
different hazards as well where if I
defeat three enemies with a certain move
or if I dodge five times it will inflict
some sort of hazard on to the other
player that I'm competing against you do
three rounds whoever does it the most or
wins out them all wins the danger and
you choose your characters whichever you
love as I would recommend yes it's a
great it's a great great division you
know now I'm gonna play it but someone
kill the Avatar gear let's at least
knock him out and then maybe we should
play one round Oh
[Music]
any tips for getting into the video game
industry out of college or maybe Marvel
games in particular you know it's it's
so bizarre you know comics and and and
video games too you know in terms of per
game to the end of it I've never known
to people taking the same path to get
through the door it also sorry you know
I wish there was a set path because in a
lot of industries there are you start
out point a B and you work your way
through the but you know I I got here by
kind of random circumstance that you
know I had been working for a long time
and the the right opportunity presented
itself at multiple games and that led to
many of the other things I've done we in
the gaming it just kind of cascaded from
there
in terms of somebody who's in college
coming this make sure that you're you
know looking at your focus in four
studies to gear it towards something
that will be valuable to a team and that
can be any of any number things because
in the gaming environment there are so
many different types of opposites needed
there are so many different types of
writers and designers needed that if
you're we spawn one thing not
necessarily necessarily strong in
another great at 2d design but not great
at design there are still opportunities
for it and I think that's a great thing
about comics too is I grew up thinking
that I could never work in comics
because I'm not a great artist but when
I started to realize that equal age that
hate to different people write and draw
the book I realize I can still tell them
good story and I can see it ahead when I
write it so if I can write it in the way
that somebody else could I could draw it
then maybe it'll work and it did so you
know it's it's about finding what or
specialism making sure that you're you
know as strong as possible it can be in
that aprea and then go there what I
think the thing that struck me most was
no too passive the same
and that yeah that really that's
something that's really important
because you can it's so hard to can't
compare yourself to but I know it's easy
to do that but as soon as you compare
yourself to somebody else you're not
giving yourself what you deserve and and
the work that you've put into your life
in your work
yeah so alright here we go
I've add I've made a Danger Room the
password is one two three as well I
should be able to find it I'm choosing
so the levels let me give you my levels
of my characters that I choose things so
you know my infinite Thanos Thanos
infinite is 231 my Wolverine is 178 my
Daredevils 148 and my Magneto's 120 nice
so I don't know if you have any 200
characters but don't use them so what
you doing that I'll explain a little bit
more about danger so as you see in the
top right there are three rounds to
danger room we are going to be competing
with each other live basically and we're
choosing gamma which is level 100 there
are three of them alpha see what the
three are so Delta oh there's so there's
tons Alpha Beta Gamma Delta Epsilon but
we're gonna go ahead and do gamma cuz
level 100 I think is good we could you
play you converse the computer you
converse players around one ways to
defeat all the bosses around to defeat
five bosses around three defeat the most
enemies
whoever can do it the fastest wins that
round and then you could beat those
rounds
all right I've destroyed my ISO eight
I'm coming into the room here oh there
yeah what is your favorite roster to
play with so yeah
I'll let you do that one my favorite
roster I play with Deadpool Ghost Rider
Wolverine and then I swap out Vulcan fan
O's as needed depending on whether I
need just a strong heavy hitter or
cosmic so before I got the nose I would
do psylocke daredevil Wolverine and
maybe Elektra four would be mine because
I'm all about speed and hack and slash
in a way all about that sometimes I
would replace a lecture with
Nightcrawler just because of that x-men
duality if you will and then Phoenix
Phoenix would be another favorite of
mine as well number what number levels
are yours
oh gosh Wolverine Deadpool and Ghost
Rider are around 130 again phantom is
around two-30 oh this is pretty okay
cool I was afraid you
here we go okay I was gonna try and ask
you a bunch of questions while we're
doing this to distract you it is it's a
it's a fun fun thing to check while
we're playing it because it gives a lot
of good memories as I'm going through
the levels getting to explain how we
made them are you the type for this game
are you the type of player that goes
straight into the action and or do you
like to go from afar range and maybe you
know shoot projectiles or like dodge you
know dodge and block more I'm a Bonin
guy I like to go right into the action I
like to claw my way through things
Wolverine tends to be my point man then
levels and so it's a I'm a hack and
slash kind of guy when it comes to my
gameplay style though it depends on the
level it depends on the type of
situation that we're in for instance you
can't do that as much an exam turns and
also getting in there and fighting some
minions
so I'm on the Left I'm at the top I'm in
the red he's in the blue and it shows
you the percentage of
Square and Sandman terrible well you
already had the destroyer yeah
he wants that my gosh there's so much
happening on the screen right now
yes
trying I have a reputation
I wonder I wonder if I could do more
damage to salmon without
yeah yeah that's cement feature that I
was like I wonder if it's strong enough
to defeat sin man without snow round
complete all right so round one is let
me oh okay all right so now because I
won the round one I can choose a victory
bonus
I'm gonna go stagger damage boost
stagger my opinion is very very
important to get out of the way
immediately so round to defeat five
bosses Emma Dimas supergiant cull
obsidian Corvus glaive and Proxima
midnight as they appear sure sir
Ghost Rider is one of my favorite
characters his chain whip and his
motorcycles circle what soon as I walked
I was like crazed yeah even the Hellfire
blast from his mouth I'm all about that
area of effect at AoE so I call con
daredevil
so as you guys see on the right side
the right side there's gonna be a bunch
of hazards that pop up and as long as
they can either one of us could do those
hazards then it hurts the other team
mark are there any story elements from
books you've written that you
incorporated into the not necessarily
from stuff that I've written
but certainly from stuff throughout
market systems so it was you know there
are nods to so many that we couldn't
resist putting in because it was such a
rich but no I didn't I didn't put in
anything necessarily that I have written
as
oh you're crushing me try it
I gotta I gotta come back
have you do so you defeated Coulson
already or no yeah
I do not like the ebony ball but just
because I liked him in the game I just
don't like playing against him but he
should be that's exactly
oh it's like Nichkhun back
[Music]
do it do what we do it
they're a lovely couple aren't they yeah
right lovely I don't know if I'd use
that word to describe it what is your
holidays who carves the turkey
those Phoenix force enhancements are
really nice yep you got it nice well
done well done it's tied one to one sign
up so this third round this is it yeah
so you get to choose a bonus yep yep
I've got game passive EP regeneration a
defense boost or increase EP or drop
rate I'm gonna go with passive
regeneration
okay so fret Oh defeat the most enemies
okay who are you primarily using are you
primarily using Thanos infinite I'm
switching back and forth I was I find
that those black order characters all
have different kind of specialty attacks
that that react better of different
fighters so for instance you know I was
getting up close when it came to a buddy
maw but with it's a little bit tougher
to do with call obsidian so he needs a
little ranged attack sometimes because
his charges will just blow you right off
tinkle
yeah so we haven't yet I we talked about
Corvus glaive there's our ebony maw a
Corvus glaive someone chats like cold
city and was my op was the hardest
person for me to fight he stopped when
he doing the actual levels that you
gotta time it out but to you know it's
way and then also you know attacking
them in between when he's stunned but
then there are other sections of the
game where you don't necessarily have
that option you may be teamed up black
or it's just chaos
yeah Jennifer do you guys think who do
you guys think is gonna win
[Music]
what no you can't say that no chats
gonna vote for you because
[Laughter]
so we have to use some solo a lot at
least with my with my team yep well and
he's he's so he's just so powerful it's
it's very rare do you really need a
synergy with him yeah but
[Music]
Wolverine went down what how oh oh oh
you're crushing me now where did you
come from i bided my time job I like it
like like the game itself I like a scope
how are these gonna be so powerful
what's happening why can't it revive
these people this is only a 30 enemy gap
Oh Oh No sportvan some challenge in
these levels absorbing those Phoenix
players me that's what I'm gonna do I
spent a little too much time sucking
them up with Wolverine early on it
rushed it's not even a chance nine
seconds left
oh my goodness and just like that I've
held my reputation that's great I mean
I'm gonna lose I might as well lose to
the writer of the game man that was
awesome guys that is Danger Room as you
can see I've faced off against mark that
was that was live that's awesome
whoo so many so many more so that's all
this there's a Dark Phoenix part here we
go that's the danger room epilogue
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
so we time well call it time everyone's
a winner here oh man
mark thank you so so much
what an amazing stream guys this is
Marvel Ultimate Alliance 3 the black
order exclusively for the switch the DLC
with all three DLC packs are out the
season pass grab them grab the game
check it out we had mark Zoomer act the
writer of the game here with us mark do
you have any last words to your fellow
fans just thank you so much for playing
it has been an absolute blast to work on
this game and to see people out there
really enjoying it for the last year and
watch the excitement is ELC so it's been
a real pleasure to be a part of this
experience and I hope you go out there
and keep enjoying it for time to come
awesome you guys thank you so much mark
everyone in chat thank you guys so much
for watching
this is Marvel your universe
you